-I'm a fan of yours
for a long time,
and I really enjoyed this film.
It's a strange, beautiful film.
You speak of a creature
in the clip.
But tell us a little bit.
Cold war.
-Yes.
It's set in the early '60s.
The facility, the lab,
is in Baltimore.
Just outside of Baltimore.
And, yes, my character,
I'm a colonel in the army.
And I go down and I find this
thing in the Amazon River.
And we're trying to figure out
what makes it work.
It's an amphibious being.
It can be in the water
and the land.
And it's kind of tied
into the Cold War.
The Americans and the Russians
trying to figure out
if there is anything --
any kind of advantage they can
get from this creature.
-You know, a lot of creatures
these days are CGI.
That is not the case
in this film.
And you were very cruel
to the creature,
which may be difficult,
because this was an actual --
there was an actor
in here the whole time.
-Oh, yeah, there was a fella
in there, Doug Jones.
If you're familiar with
Guillermo del Toro's movies,
Doug has played several
creatures for Guillermo.
-Yeah, "Pan's Labyrinth"
and "Hellboy."
-The one with the eyes
in the hand.
I don't know if this means
anything to you.
But, yeah, Doug is kind of --
I've described him
as Guillermo's monk.
And Guillermo seems to like
that description.
He kind of --
Guillermo comes up with the most
fantastical beings imaginable.
And Doug makes them a reality
along with, obviously,
the design of the costume.
But I think the main pain Doug
experienced was in his knees
because he had to spend a lot of
time on his knees in the lab.
I don't think --
as far as I can tell,
we don't have any sour grapes
between us.
-Oh, that's good.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Like, when it was all over,
he didn't sort of
passive aggressively
talk about his knees?
-No, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
He's a very thin, thin man.
And the suit is, like,
made out of rubber.
So it's basically like
kneeling on a dish sponge
for, you know, five hours.
That's what I mean --
he's like a monk.
He's just very, you know --
he can go to another realm.
So me, like, prodding him is
not really that big a deal.
-There are some beautiful
old Cadillacs in this film.
Your character purchases one.
Is it true
that you actually, like,
ruined one of the Cadillacs?
-Yeah, we had an incident
one night.
There's a scene --
it's part of a chase sequence,
where I'm trying to figure out
what's going on.
The creature has disappeared.
And so my character
is in a mad dash
going here, there,
and everywhere
trying to find the creature.
And there's a scene
where I pull up in an old car,
and run into this building, run
up this fire escape in the rain.
It's raining. It's night.
You know, it's very dramatic.
And it's an old car,
so the dash doesn't light up.
So it's really hard to see
what gear you're in.
[ Laughter ]
So the second take we did,
I thought I clicked over
into park, but I hadn't.
And I was halfway out
and I realized
the car was still rolling.
And I tried to get my hand
back on the gearshift.
But I was, like,
sliding onto the ground.
And the car just very slowly
ran into this --
like, a light post or something.
[ Laughter ]
And ironically, they wound up
using the first take.
[ Laughter ]
So didn't really even need to do
the second take.
-Oh, gotcha. Yeah.
-It was totally unnecessary.
But Guillermo did say that
because I was able to get rid of
that light post,
he was able to do another shot
he really wanted to do,
that the light post had actually
been in his way.
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
So you actually did a great
favor to the production.
-Yeah, yeah.
So if he wins, you know, best
director, he has me to thank.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
I've also read that you --
in between takes on film, which
can sometimes be really long --
I don't think people quite
understand how much time
is between the moments
you actually act.
People think
you're in character,
but that is incorrect.
-No, I'm just tired.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm tired.
It's a really long day.
And I find
small talk exhausting, so...
Just kidding.
[ Laughter ]
No, so I -- I try to just kind
of -- and also, you know,
the thing about it is, like,
I'm used to doing theater.
I did a lot of theater
starting out in Chicago.
And I -- some people say,
"How do you do something over
and over and over again?"
But I love repetition.
Because as far as I'm concerned,
you never get it perfect.
You never get it exactly right.
And there's something you're
always --
it's not so much, like,
you can go deeper
in your character or whatever.
It's just more like,
"What am I not noticing?
What am I
not paying attention to?
What other response
could I have?"
It's just --
it's more like chess to me,
trying to figure out the exact
way through it. Yeah.
-But do you find in film that --
Do you have the amount of
repetition you have in theater?
Or is it just --
-Sometimes.
Guillermo says, you know --
Because Guillermo is a real
perfectionist, very obsessive.
And he's like, "I may have met
my match in Michael Shannon."
He would be happy to --
He's like, "We got it.
Let's move on."
I'm like, "One more?"
He's like,
"What are you going to do?"
And I'm like, "I don't know!
Let's do it again!"
-Meanwhile, Doug's on his knees
being like, "One more?"
-He's like, "Yeah, 10 more!
Please!
I don't need these things."